今日は、人類の夢について話そうと思う
君たち！我々人類の夢とは何か、知っているかね？
そう！
空へ行くことだ。
我々はー、古く昔から空を飛ぶことを考え、様々な挑戦をしてきた
飛行機を作ったり、ジェット機を作ったり
あらゆる手段を利用してー、我々はー、空を飛ぼうと頑張ってきた
だが！人類自身で空を飛ぶということは、いまだ！叶っていない
我々は様々な努力をし、色々な知恵を振り絞り、空へ行くことだけを考えた！！
ずばあぁぁあす！！！
まぁ簡単に言いますと、紙飛行機っていうものがありますよ
いや、これはねすごいよ！マジで、ビッグな買い物だよ！
いやいやいや、これはすごいでしょ
こちら
体験！！世界一の紙ヒコーキ
すぐに飛ばせる！自分で作れる！
これが世界記録のキングサイズだ！っつってね
紙飛行機が入ってます
まぁー・・・紙飛行機を買ったのか・・・
（苦笑）
勘弁してくれ
これ何円ぐらいだっけな～
えっ、でも800円とかした気がすんだけど
紙飛行機で800円ですよ！
なぜここでホットと言ったのか、自分でも、わからなかった…
いやいや、ついに、時代も変わりましたなー
じゃあちょっと、開けていきましょう
ほー。わ、いろいろ書いてありますね
あー、なるほど。紙飛行機の解説とかが書いてあります
いろいろ書いてありますね。ふーん
え！？滞空時間ギネス世界記録29秒らしいです
おぉ～。飛ばし方とか、どういう風に折ったらいいかとか書いてある
麩
うわ、すっごい難しいなこれガチだわ！ガチなやつだよこれ
すごい、色んな紙飛行機の種類があるんすね
スカイキング
ウイングエース
フライヤー
コンコルド
ロングプレーン
ランサー
フィーストゥン
立体ステルス
スペースシャトル型
うわ、すごいなー、飛行リングなんてあんのぉ？
もぉ～すごいよ、か、も、紙、飛行機ですら
バキって言っちゃったよ
飛行機、でーすらないのもありますからね
まぁでも今回の意味はそこじゃないんですよ
僕のお目当てはこちらのですね
スカイキングなんで
もう作ってあるからー、もう完成してますからね
既に世界記録ですから
800円で世界記録が手に入るなんて、安いもんだよ
おぉー
すごいよぉー
紙飛行機がついてんだよ
うわ、怖ッッ！！これ大丈夫か
取っていいんだよね
これかー
これが世界一の紙飛行機、スカイキングです
これが世界一か
これ普通になんか、俺も作れる気がす・・・
いやいやいや、そんなことはないよ
きっとすごい飛ぶんすよ
あぁー　いける気はするわー　いける気はする
滞空時間のギネス世界記録は、29秒2なので、僕はそれを超えて、40秒8を出します
任せてください
俺は今日！世界の記録を塗り替える
では、いこう
完全にバカにしてる人と思われちゃうな
上にあげたらいいんだよね　いきます！
3(スリー)、  2(トゥー)、  1(ワン)
あれおかしいな、もっと
えー、待って　これ本当に世界一なの？
ほっ
あぁー、今のすごいよかった　今よかったよかった
しっかりと、このー
羽の上下のー、高さが同じぐらいなってるとちゃんとまっすぐ飛びます
ほら
おっ！？
いやいやいや、俺ちょっといい線きてんじゃないすか！？
だいすけのち○こ当てゲームしようぜ
よーし　だいすけのちんこに当たったら、俺の勝ちだ
ほっ
お！
あぁー惜しい　だいすけのちんこに当たってほしい
下を
うわ！いてててて　びっくりした　死ぬかと思った
ほっ！
うわぁ！ちょっと待って
あ！
今感じた　俺が感じた　これ強く投げるやつだ
うっ！
え！すごい楽しい！
待って待って
これ強く投げたら楽しいやつだ
ぉ、お、ほ、ほ、ほ
うわ！
戻ってくるよ、これ
おぉ～
おっぷううぅぅうう！！！
戻ってくるんですけど
あ、ぐしゃってなっちゃった
はっ！
おぉ～～！！
飽きちゃった
これちょっと自分でカスタマイズした方がいい気がすんだよな
世界一には、申し訳ないんですけど、
私なりのカスタマイズをしてみましょう
スピードだけを求めた最強の紙飛行機が出来ました
これで世界を取りに行こうと思います
いきます
ほっ！
チーン。